this season on 90 day fiancé I didn't
fall in love with Annie's body I fell in
love with any mind
nataly's full of life and she brings
excitement every day Mike will be here
soon visa so I'm here to get me some
Botox baby I don't think it's realistic
right now to have a child I literally
have a clock inside me telling me you
need to have a kid now is something new
it's yeah you don't think you could be
Jasmine's lottery ticket out here
my friends think Jasmine's using me to
be in the United States with her sister
but I'm not worried what I want from you
is to not parent I am their mom and
nobody will ever know that better than I
do
how does immersed out family feel about
your kids result doesn't want to tell
his family it's painful there's no rule
that says you have to marry him it's a
father there's a pattern he gets someone
pregnant it all falls apart what
you found Robert on the internet and
then all of a sudden you're here in
America this old lady come with us
attitude to me please you finish I'm
gonna work I'm gonna get it
Teddy joke I'm telling you though I
don't have much more time everything
comes to a boiling point than that
explodes
I'm not include that another Island
making you look much other Europe do
they want either leave soon yes maybe
I'm not supposed to be happy I don't
know
you love Mike
brat for me
I'm going back through the back
[Music]